tenable ukraine's also calling for an
urgent ceasefire to restore power to the
chernobyl uh plant because of fears of a
potential radioactive leak skies ashish
joshi reports
they're looking for survivors or the
injured
anyone who might still be alive under
the debris
this building like so many in sumi in
northeastern ukraine reduced to
splinters
this video was shot by ukrainian
emergency services
first responders in a war zone when so
many need help
russia dropped here bombs and you can
see that the whole area is totally
destroyed this is what happens after
relentless russian bombardment
neighborhoods like this one in harkev
turned into ghost towns devoid of all
life
and no knowing when it will return
the russian invasion has entered its
14th day
the plea for western intervention
still is strong today
as it was two weeks ago
from the first day of the russian
invasion ukraine keeps telling our
partners that if you don't close the
airspace over ukraine you will be
responsible for ukrainian people's death
team
russia uses missiles and bombs to kill
our people to target our infrastructure
this is a responsibility a moral duty of
the world to help us
we've got a war we don't have time for
all these mediation and discussions
it's not a ping pong game we are talking
about people's lives
make this decision quickly please send
us fighter jets
russia is keen to show the world the
might of its military muscle
moscow no doubt stung by western
analysis suggesting its advance is
behind schedule
its defense ministry has shared footage
of armored columns and attack
helicopters it claims are in action in
ukraine
and it also wants to show the world that
it is responding to the humanitarian
crisis that it has itself created
moscow shared these pictures of aid
being distributed among residents of a
village outside hakeem
but as it continues its offensive on the
ground
moscow has also stepped up its
diplomatic attack on ukraine
accusing it of using biological weapons
we confirmed that during the special
military operation we uncovered certain
facts we uncovered this urgent cover-up
of vestitures of programmes that were
being run in laboratories we can't be
talking about the use of these
laboratories for peaceful purposes
these labs were financed by the u.s
ministry of defense
we can conclude that in ukrainian
laboratories close to our borders
components of biological weapons were
being developed the urgent destruction
of these materials was ordered in order
not to disclose the materials and the
programs that were being developed there
over two million people have now fled
this conflict
and ukrainians continue to pour over her
borders
seeking safety desperate families torn
from loved ones
some who remain behind facing an
increasingly uncertain future
ukraine's capital
has yet to fall but fighting inches ever
closer
this surreal show of defiance the kiev
classic symphony orchestra performing in
the city's maydown square
for the residents who were still here
they played the eu's adopted anthem owed
to joy
but there is little of that here
ashish joshi sky news
well let's take you live now to la viv
in western ukraine and our security and
defense editor deborah haynes uh deborah
first of all let's take a look at what
uh defense secretary ben wallace just
had to say uh in his briefing at the
house of commons talking about the uk
considering sending air defense and
anti-tank missiles to ukraine
yes he was updating the house on the
uk's contribution to support the
ukrainian armed forces the uk was the
first european nation to send in these
defensive weapons as he describes them
and he said that in in terms of the
number of anti-tank weapons that have
been sent in already it's more than 3
600 now which is up from 2000 at the
beginning of the war nearly two weeks
ago and he also said that they were
going to start sending in another form
of anti-tank uh missile the javelin um
and he said that they were considering
sending in anti-air missiles as well now
this is the thing that the ukrainians
have been crying out for they've been
very um appreciative of the anti-tank
weapons it must be said i mean that's
one of the uh reasons why the ukrainian
military have been able to take out so
many russian tanks and other armoured
vehicles
but clearly they're concerned about the
the ability of russia to
fly still in their skies drop
bombs on residential areas they say or
bombs on their cities also launching
missiles against them and that's
something that an anti-aircraft system
could help i mean the one that the uk is
talking about isn't the sort of um much
larger system that can shoot jets out
the skies it's the more the sort of uh
system that could take out helicopters
for example but right now clearly from
the ukrainian side anything that can
help bolster the abilities of their
armed forces
are welcome but i thought it was
interesting um in the uk defense
secretary's explanation to mps if the
help that the uk has given giving he
says that everything they do he
describes it as defensive weapons he
also says that it's carefully calibrated
um to make sure that they are support
supplying these defensive weapons um not
to a level that would then maybe trigger
more of a kind of a strategic
help from the uk which then that russia
could perhaps view as the uk becoming
directly involved in military
confrontation here in ukraine that's
something that nato allies all seem to
be very carefully trying to avoid but
it's not a black and white um situation
is it it's very gray and so when does a
level of military support from a nation
to another nation at war cross that line
into um being kind of seen by the other
side as direct military intervention at
the moment we're not there but clearly
the defense secretary very alive to that
issue
yeah the language picked clearly very
very careful there wasn't a defensive
weapons used and deborah also want to
bring up with you uh the fact that while
pm cues was on air and we were listening
to prime minister boris johnson
ukrainian authorities said that power
had been knocked out at chernobyl
nuclear plant amid russia the russian
invasion and the emergency generators
had to be turned on
yes well this well it's one of the the
areas that have caused real
international concern is any activities
around these nuclear plants obviously
the one in chernobyl um is uh you know
it's not um operational in any sense
that it was before but clearly that was
the the site of the the world's worst
nuclear disaster um you know outside of
a war
in terms of that what happened in the
1980s in chernobyl and then there's been
concerns too hasn't there about the
other nuclear plant that um the largest
one in europe that's in the center of
ukraine that too uh came under fire
under russian fire during the war and um
russian military personnel are on that
site too and there are ukrainians still
operating both of those sites but
clearly um it's not no longer under
ukrainian control and the international
atomic energy agency has been really
sounding the alarm about this and has
been saying you'll remember that they've
been offering the head of the iaea has
even offered to come to chernobyl to
speak to the two parties and try to
agree some sort of framework to ensure
the safety of these plants i mean any
disaster any nuclear disaster
in any of ukraine's nuclear power plants
wouldn't just be a catastrophe for
ukraine but could potentially be a
catastrophe for a much wider area in
europe so it's clearly a problem um
that's uh every now and again like we're
hearing today um being illuminated when
the actual circumstances at the
particular site changes
debra home security and defense editor
live from levitt thanks very much indeed
right well let's take a closer look then
at the situation on the ground in
ukraine for you thomas more is here with
me in the studio as well as air marshall
edward stringer thomas
it is two weeks since russia invaded
ukraine and i am joined by uh air
marshal edward stringer director of
former director of operations at the
ministry of defense um ed this is not
the the picture that president putin
would hope to see at this stage
no and um
you can see it's not really changed that
much significantly in the last week it's
important to say that for
russia to take ukraine it's not as
simplistic as stationing a soldier on
every square yard of the country so you
wouldn't see the map go red but we can
also see that their their plan now is
revealed and it was a two or three day
operation to seize the major seats of
national government
replace the government with a puppet
regime turn ukraine into a client state
and assume that 44 million ukrainians
would go along with that let's take a
look at what's happening in the north of
ukraine then
and we can see there uh that they are
still uh hoping to keep open those
humanitarian corridors uh out of uh sumi
and also to the from the towns uh west
of uh kiev uh but it is the the military
situation around the capital uh that uh
that you're that you want to talk about
yes well one of the bits that has
changed over the last week is this is
this apparent thrust here
almost pure east to west towards uh uh
kiev
and that's in contrast to where the
initial north to south line was and
we've been covering over the last two
weeks that convoy that has got stalled
and increasingly it looks like the
russians have created their own 40-mile
roadblock and this may well be that they
have to open another line of
communication here this is yet another
logistic challenge and it seems to be
they're trying to double down and come
up with a plan b when they didn't have
one and it looks like increasingly it's
pressure on kiev to try and reach some
form of acceptable solution and the
ukrainian government has been looking
for
more air power and there's been an
interesting development overnight the
suggestion if we look at the wider
picture uh now a suggestion uh from
poland that they give up their mig-29 uh
soviet era fighter jets and give them to
nato probably to the ramstein air base
in germany nato then
hand them on to ukraine but the
americans have said that is not a
situation they would get involved in why
i as i understand uh
the plan before
the americans turned it off is that the
the polls would fly the aircraft to
germany where they would be essentially
rebadged as ukrainian it doesn't then
really matter who flies them from
ukraine into ukraine let's assume it is
ukra ukrainian pilots you have warplanes
getting airborne from a nato a german
and a us base about the biggest there is
flying directly into a war zone and and
therefore into combat that's getting
very close to nato getting directly
involved in this confrontation so
perception of american fingerprints on
those fighter jets and that's not a
situation that nato would want uh
marshall thank you very much indeed
thank you
well here boris johnson says he expects
the number of visas issued to ukrainian
refugees to rise to the hundreds of
thousands so far 957
uk visas have been granted and 22 000
applications have been made
we've already got a thousand people in
under the existing scene that number
will climb uh very sharply mr speaker no
one has been turned away mr speaker that
is that is simply we want we want to be
as generous and well mr speaker it is
important to have checks let me make
this point to the house because i do
think it's i think people need to
understand there are some people there
are some people mr speaker who would i
like to dispense with checks all
together and simply to wave people
through and i've got to say and and i
hear these and i hear the voices on the
benches opposite i i think that is i do
think that that is irresponsible and and
that is not the approach that we should
be taking the schengen countries have a
different arrangement we must be in no
doubt as i said in answer to a previous
question the kremlin has singled out
this country for the approach that we
are taking vladimir putin and we know
how unscrupulous putin can be in his
methods it would not be right mr speaker
to expose this country to unnecessary
security risk and we will not do it mr
speaker we are going to be as generous
as we can possibly be but we must have
checks
right well meanwhile un refugee agency
says nearly 2.2 million people have now
fled ukraine let's break that down for
you then of those nearly 1.3 million
have crossed into poland
more than 200 000 have gone to hungary
which has changed its earlier hardline
policy on accepting refugees more than
150 000 have crossed into slovakia
more than 85 000 ukrainian residents are
now in romania and there is a similar
number in moldova too it's important to
note that huge numbers have already
passed through after arriving in these
countries more than 230 000 are now in
other european countries and nearly a
hundred thousand people
are reported to have left for russia
well i'm joined now by skies laura
bundock in calais uh laura tell us about
the scene there and of course
extraordinary reports uh that we we have
been covering of people arriving in
calais only to be turned away
yeah well this is the situation right
now so this is the youth hostel behind
me where there are lots of ukrainians
they've been arriving steadily here over
the past few days we're expecting a bus
to turn up at some point it's already
late and it is said to be taking some
ukrainians to a visa application center
but we don't know who it's taking and we
don't even know which center it's meant
to be going to it could be paris it
could be brussels or it could be this
new temporary pop-up center in lille we
just don't know and i think that paints
the picture of the amount of confusion
the complex situation that is facing the
ukrainians as they arrive here now i met
uh muhammad he's travelled from key with
his wife her daughter and some friends
they have been catching trains for days
they went through slovakia austria
germany france ending up here in calais
he thought he'd be on a ferry by now to
the uk where he has family and they are
going to welcome him in they said but he
realizes he needs this visa he has on
spec gone to paris this lunch time to
try and get an appointment there that's
not what the home office says he should
do they say you need to book the
appointment and then go to it but he was
very surprised and frustrated by the
difficulty he faces going to the uk when
he has family there he says he said it
is a complex a difficult way of getting
in we also met the boletina family now
they drove here uh in their car taking
with them their dog and their three
guinea pigs everything they can carry
they've also left kiev they've got their
appointment booked in paris tomorrow but
they know it could be a long wait before
they get the decision and i met this
young couple anatoly and natalya and
they too drove across from the polish
border
taking their most precious possession a
scan of their unborn baby natalia is 14
weeks pregnant she had this scan
uh the day before she decided she had to
leave ukraine now they've been told it's
a five-day wait to find out if their
visa will be approved
they are just sat inside she is pregnant
they are waiting they simply do not know
they do not know the baby's due in
september they don't know where they
will be living them and they just don't
know where their baby will be born it is
a pretty bleak picture here in calais
today
for us to give us an idea of what people
are going through thanks very much
indeed
well while the uk's refugee scheme has
been criticized for its slow start
ireland says it's now taken more than 2
500 refugees from ukraine
live then to dublin airport and our
island correspondent stephen murphy
stephen island uh comparatively doing
all it can to help refugees coming from
ukraine with a woeful response from the
uk
well a really steady stream of ukrainian
arrivals here in dublin airport we're in
the arrival tour of terminal one here at
the moment and a really steady stream
it's just talking to a gentleman from
county carlo who said he was uh moved to
come down by the coverage he saw on sky
news to volunteer his spare rooms in his
house he's now collecting uh two
ukrainian families uh from a flight from
dusseldorf never met them before in his
life he's gonna drive them down an hour
and a half south and uh host them for as
long as needs be around 400 or so per
day are arriving here at dublin airport
the true figure may be higher the irish
government only has statistics uh for
dublin airport not the other ports of
entry uh we just saw the justice
minister uh down here as well a desk has
been set up where the the new rivals are
given leaflets outlining the social
protections they're entitled to work
their children are entitled to access
education housing will be provided we
appreciate this may be a very difficult
time for you and your family is how this
information starts off it's available
obviously in ukrainian and russian as
well not everybody though appears to be
quite
so enthused about ireland's open door
policy reports in the last 24 hours or
so that there are those within the
british government have certain security
concerns given that ireland uh with its
open door policy to ukrainians here has
obviously an open border with the united
kingdom uh about an hour and a half
north from here uh in the uk so i put
that and those concerns to the irish
justice minister helen mcity about an
hour ago and this is what she had to say
in reply
i think the conversations that i have
with pretty patel are the most important
not perhaps reports that i read on a
newspaper i'm very confident and happy
with the conversations that we've had
but you don't understand the concerns
expressed
i think we all have to be vigilant i
think we all need to make sure that
anybody coming into our country be it
ireland or any other country any other
member state or beyond that we take the
appropriate measures and checks to make
sure the people are who they say they
are
and that of course is happening in this
instance where information can be shared
and provided to the uk and the home
office that that is being done
the minister was also extremely clear
that the common travel area arrangement
that's free movement between britain and
ireland would be in no way impacted by
the current crisis so for the moment
here at dublin airport as i said the
steady stream we're expecting between
four and 500 more ukrainian citizens to
arrive here continues and they have been
given temporary protection measures they
can stay here for a maximum of up to
three years and as i was just saying
there are ordinary irish people here as
well as ukrainian relatives opening
their homes to these new arrivals
stephen thanks very much indeed good to
see a positive response out of
all of this destruction you're watching
sky news coming up we speak to the world
nuclear association amid concern about
the ongoing situation at chernobyl
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
and over there is dover we track the
changes happening to our world right now
i think it's a procession of the taliban
there they are right here would you as
prime minister be able to look them in
the face let's have a look at both of
those two things i just want to say
thank you for having the courage to
speak to us we do genuinely believe in
what we do to show the truth
i thought there was an astonishing story
there
[Music]
welcome back while the war in ukraine is
having a global economic impact fuel
prices at uk four courts have hit
another record high and according to
data firm experian catalyst the average
cost of a litre of petrol was 158 to
20 yesterday while diesel uh reached
165.20
our business presenter ian king joins me
now from the city ian
thanks simon well a host of big european
companies have today been joining in
with the sanctions against russia have
announced today that they're suspending
or shutting their operations in russia
the french cosmetics giant l'oreal
announced that it's closing its stores
in russia and it's suspending
investments in the country and it also
said it would be donating five million
euros to charities and organizations
supporting humanitarian aid to ukraine
meanwhile heineken the world's second
biggest brewer said it was stopping the
production advertising and sale of its
brand in russia it also attacked the
russian government for launching what it
called an unprovoked and completely
unjustified attack on ukraine well that
news follows last night's announcements
from mcdonald's pepsico coca-cola and
young brands the owner of kfc and pizza
hut that they were suspending operations
in russia
meanwhile unilever the company behind
dove and lifeboy soap magnum ben and
jerry's ice cream and domestos
disinfectant has suspended all inputs
ports and exports of its products into
and out of russia and it's to stop all
media and advertising spending in the
country alan jope unilever's chief
executive said the company would not
invest any further capital into the
country and would not be profiting from
its presence in russia however while
condemning the war in ukraine as a
brutal and senseless act by the russian
state the company said that it would for
now continue to supply everyday
essential food and hygiene products made
in russia to the people of the country
meanwhile another german car maker has
been forced to suspend production due to
a shortage of parts from ukraine porsche
said it was suspending production of its
electric take-home model in stuttgart
due to a shortage of wire harnesses
that's equipment which bundles together
up to three miles worth of electric
cabling in the typical car all these
were previously supplied by the
ukrainian company leone it follows a
similar move last week from volkswagen
which has had to suspend production at
two of its german plants putting eight
thousand workers on furlough a third
german car maker bmw has also warned of
interruptions to production
well all eyes continue to be on the oil
price following last night's news that
the us and uk to stop importing russian
crude and crude products here's the
current price of brent crude currently
trading at 124.33
cents a barrel that is down by just shy
of three percent on the day meanwhile
the price of natural gas has eased after
it of course hit eight pounds a thumb on
monday having closed last night at 511
pfirm it was trading at four pounds and
seven pence a short while ago on the
equity markets following a fall on wall
street last night there were more
overnight declines in the asia-pacific
region the nikkei 225 in tokyo fell for
the fourth straight session to hit a
16-month low while there were also
declines in hong kong and in shanghai
the markets in europe have bounced this
morning staged a solid rally here's the
current picture as you can see all of
the main european indices up by uh in
some cases five percent or more they are
moving milan up by five and a quarter
percent the dax in germany up by just
north of five percent sentiment appears
to have been lifted by reports that the
eu may issue bonds to finance spending
on energy and defense we're here in
london the ftse 100 is also in positive
territory currently up one and
three-quarter percent in what looks to
be a broad-based rally the leading blue
chip gainer in percentage terms right
now is electro components that is a
parts distributor and that is on the
back of a trading update the share is
currently nearly nine percent to the
good the fund manager m g which had
results out earlier this week it shares
also ahead by more than eight percent
outside the ftse 100 the bus and coach
operator stage coach it shares currently
up some 36 and a quarter percent that is
on news of a takeover following it at
595 million pounds on the foreign
exchange markets meanwhile sterling had
been drifting earlier on against the us
dollar the dollar very much in demand
since russia launched its invasion of
ukraine sterling currently though up by
a third of one percent against the
greenback it's off by half of one
percent right now against the euro we
have a rates decision from the european
central bank tomorrow
well joining me now is the chief market
analyst markets.com neil wilson neil
welcome to you what's behind this rally
do you think i mean it's a pretty
spectacular move upwards for european
equities today
yeah it is i mean i think you're right
pointing out that certain news about the
eu maybe issuing joint bonds you know
anything that sort of nudges uh the
european union towards more fiscal union
is sort of lapped up by the market we've
also got expectation uh for the ecb
tomorrow i think potentially
someone some in the market thinking they
might be uh doing something big
uh but also you know you have to look at
this as a bit of a you know a bit of a
debt cap outside i feel
um the
the technicals may be looking a bit
oversold
compelling valuations because because
prices have come down so much um but
you've still got the specter of
stagflation of much slower growth
in europe and also uh you know we're
going to see guidance being being cut
quite significantly a lot of the big
european corporates as they have to uh
uh you know change their
change of production and deal with far
higher input costs from soaring
inflation so i think i think this is
probably a bit of a bear market rally
and one that will be reversed
neil we obviously heard uh yesterday
that the uk is joining the us in uh
trying to wean itself off russian oil
and gas by the end of the year there'll
be a ban on their uh russian crude
imports here to the uk uh by the end of
this year now grant chaps uh has said
this morning that uh the only way out of
this to make up this shortfall is going
to be increasing north sea oil
production how feasible do you think
that is
well i think you know in in the short
term obviously not not very um you know
the problem with oil markets and gas
markets right now is the immediate
delivery uh and that's just simply not
there we can't we can't
make that up um very quickly i think
longer term uh you could see you know
incentivization for for more oil and gas
in the north sea i don't see anything
particularly wrong with that even if
you're looking at going to 100
zero carbon you need to bridge you need
to get there now we're going to
bridge that gap with you know imports of
russian oil about ten percent or oil in
2019 i think came from from russia so
you know
we are we need to find a bridge we
obviously need to work
we want that russian oil and it you know
we also need to contend with the fact
that um you know russia might retaliate
with further sanctions on the west and
the threats in recent days to cool the
nordstrom one uh pipeline that needs to
be
you know looked at as well but i think
you know the north sea can deliver some
incremental um uh oil and gas to to the
uk but it will take time it takes about
three years for a new project to start
flowing so uh it's not a solution for
the immediate term uh i think at the
moment we'll be looking for you know
securing lng shipments and hoping and
praying that the the wing keeps blowing
uh in order to power the wind turbines
all right neil got to leave it there
neil wilson from markets.com there good
to see you neil thank you simon back to
you
ian thanks very much indeed
ukraine's government has called for an
immediate ceasefire around the chernobyl
nuclear plant to allow repairs to the
site's power supply the state-owned
nuclear company had warned that
radioactive substances could be released
into the atmosphere if power isn't
restored soon
well let's bring in jonathan cobb from
the world nuclear association he joins
me live now uh thanks very much indeed
for joining us on what is an incredibly
worrying update coming from chernobyl
just how worried should we be
i think one of the things we can bear in
mind is that the international atomic
energy agency's director general raphael
gracie has just put out a statement
um he has been informed by the ukrainian
authorities
of development such chernobyl and he
said there is no critical impact on
safety at the moment now the reasons for
that include the fact that on-site at
chernobyl like uh the active reactors
that there are in the ukraine um there
are diesel generators and these start up
very soon after any power supply loss
from the grid uh to start supplying
power to the site
the second reason is uh the
reactors at chernobyl haven't been
operating uh the last one closed in 2000
and so the fuel that was discharged from
those reactors has been cooling over
those 20 21 years
and it is now very much cooler than it
would have been when it was discharged
from the plant so that in fact on the
3rd of march the iaea released a
statement saying that in the event of
power being lost the water itself uh in
the spent fuels where the the fuel that
was discharged from the act reactors
while they were operating where that
fuel has been kept the water alone would
be sufficient to keep that uh fuel
cooled
okay well that that that's good news at
least um and how long do we expect the
diesel generators
to last uh into do you have an idea of a
time frame of how long they they can
keep things going
well the thing that probably would be
one limiting factor would be the
availability of diesel fuel
so uh in reactors there tends to be a
few days maybe up to seven days of fuel
supply available for those uh diesel
generators and so that would need to be
replenished if they were required to
operate further than that
yeah exactly and we're with so many of
uh ukraine's major cities are on
lockdown we've seen the catastrophic
situation in mariopol as well that that
that diesel getting into chernobyl is
clearly very important um
raphael grossi had also offered to visit
chernobyl or zaparizia hadn't he because
of his concerns about keeping these
nuclear plants going
um
just how concerned should we be about
the fact that this has happened now and
the potential
for uh perhaps the diesel won't get
there in time or uh do you think that
there are negotiations that must be
being
conducted as we speak to get the diesel
there in time well i think one thing to
bear in mind is that it was in fact in
the first days of the conflict that
russian forces entered the site at
chernobyl so there are russian forces
who are controlling the chernobyl site
at the moment and it is the ukrainian
operators who would have been there
normally and the international operators
who would be assisting them who are
carrying out the day-to-day operations
but it is being controlled by the
russians so this isn't a situation where
um the the site is within an area of
high conflict so that is something to
bear in mind that the russians are
actually operating the site so uh they
have been allowing the operators to
carry on their activities there are
concerns over the way in which the
operators are being treated for example
uh the operators haven't been allowed to
leave so although they have organized
into shifts the same operators who are
on the site when the site was taken over
by the russian forces are still working
there and that's obviously a stressful
situation to be in and and that's one
issue i know that raphael grossi uh the
director general of the iaea is wanting
to resolve
yeah of course because presumably if
people are working long hours and are
getting tired then
you don't want anyone to not have their
eye on the ball at a nuclear plant in
particular
no i mean they are very professional
people who are at that site they have
organized into shift systems uh so they
have the potential to get the rest that
they would need but clearly it is it is
not uh as good as it could be and it is
not the same as is happening at the
zapparojaya site uh which is the uh
operating nuclear plant that has also
been uh occupied by russian forces there
they are allowing uh workforces to
exchange their shifts
in a more usual fashion
right okay well um i also want to ask
you about if you have any information
about
the radiation levels coming from
chernobyl are they still normal
is there nothing to worry about as far
as that's concerned
i have no direct information on that
there were concerns raised by the iaea
that some of the automatic readings
that they would normally expect to
receive
weren't being delivered
but i don't think there's any indication
that there is an issue at present
because i refer to that statement from
rafael grossi that there is no critical
impact on safety at the moment
okay jonathan cobb from the world
nuclear association thanks very much
indeed
and a reminder that here on sky news
we're keeping you up to date with all
the latest on the situation in ukraine
every day we are bringing you special
programs like this one with all the
day's developments the next will be at
seven o'clock this evening
and to let you know that uh tonight
we're also running a special program
looking at president putin's invasion
tactics that's putin's war the battle
for ukraine this evening at 9 30 p.m
here on sky news
this is sky news today coming up as the
war continues to devastate ukraine i'll
be speaking to the managing director of
operations at the world bank to discuss
the financial impact on the country
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
more now on the financial situation
arising from the russian invasion and
the world bank has approved an emergency
financing package of more than 700
million dollars for ukraine joining me
now from berlin is axel van trotzenberg
who is the managing director of
operations at the world bank thanks very
much indeed for joining us um i know
typically support loans don't come with
restrictions or conditions uh can you
tell us a bit about what you expect this
money to go towards
well first of all this was an emergency
operation we prepared in less than a
week
normally these operations take months to
prepare
what we have been doing is
the ukrainian government needs
desperately a budgetary resource to play
pensioners to pay
the salaries of civil servants to
keep the health system going and there
are large needs and they need these
resources so we put a package together
that is joined by a host of countries
including britain uh to to help
financing and so we went to the board on
monday and we are proceeding with
disbursements
so so if we can break some of that down
then um it is an emergency package you
have moved to act as quickly as possible
clearly um so then countries have been
generous and uh forthcoming uh would you
say with
putting this package together
yeah okay exactly so what we have done
we originally had 350 then we got
guaranteed from sweden and from the
netherlands that allowed us to go to
about 500 million we have about 100
million parallel financing from the
japanese government and then a trust
fund was created where five countries
will put in about 134 million dollars
including 100 million from the united
states united kingdom so this is a
package that is in needed this is for us
certainly the first in an in in a set of
packages we would like to prepare the
government desperately need
international financial support so we
are prepared to provide a total of about
three billion dollars in the months
ahead
uh and and presumably as as you
mentioned briefly there that's to help
the government keep everything moving
and ticking along while it kind of
redirects a lot of its fund towards the
war effort so this is for pensions
hospital workers and social programs
that is exactly right now it is to to
keep the government going and to provide
maximum support and clearly once the uh
the war is over and its government needs
a reconstruction help we will be there
as well
and what about um support for
neighboring countries that are taking in
uh tens of thousands of refugees a
record number for europe to more than
two million now
yeah exactly that is also we are so
there is direct support to ukraine then
there is uh the next uh i'm afraid i
have to interrupt you let's take you
live now to the house of commons and
business secretary quasi quatting i'm
sure all members will join me in
thanking him once again for his
inspiring uh words his great uh
leadership
and it is with those words uh in mind
madam deputy speaker that we come well
certainly i come here uh today
with your permission madam to speak i'd
like to make a statement on the uk
phase-out of imports of russian oil in
response to vladimir putin's brutal and
illegal invasion of ukraine
the uk joins key allies including the
united states in halting the import of
russian oil which makes up 44
of russian exports and 17
of the government's
revenue through taxation
this action
follows the most punishing set of uh
sanctions that the british state has
ever imposed on a g20 nation
our trade financial and personal
sanctions are having an effect on the
russian economy the ruble as i speak has
now fallen by nearly 42
and the moscow exchanges stock trading
has been shut since the 25th of february
the british government has sent
a clear message
to
putin's regime
and to those who support him in his war
against ukraine
it is important to remember madame
deputy speaker that russia produces only
a fraction of the fuel products
currently imported to the uk
in a competitive global market for oil
and petroleum products demand
can be met by alternative sources of
supply
and as a result of international
revulsion
at putin's invasion
russian oil is already
being excluded from much of the market
and currently it is trading at quite a
sharp discount from other crude oil
sources
but we want to go further madame
definitely speaker yesterday i set out
that the uk is phasing out imports of
russian oil
during the course of the year
this transition will give the market it
will give
businesses
and supply chains more than enough time
to substitute
russian imports
businesses should use this year
to ensure
as smooth a transition as possible
so that consumers
will not be
affected
the government will work with companies
through a new task force on oil to
support them
to make use of this period in finding
alternative supplies
yesterday i spoke with businesses unions
and representatives from the sector and
of course i and officials in bays will
continue to engage and support british
business
while russian imports account for eight
percent of total uk oil demand
the uk is also one should remember a
significant producer
of both crude oil and petroleum products
we participate in a global market for
these products and we have resources in
place
in the unlikely event
of supply disruption
over the course of the year
the task force we set up will work
closely with international partners
including the usa the netherlands
and the gulf to ensure alternative
supplies of fuel products
last week
i addressed the international energy
agency and tomorrow we will have an
extraordinary meeting of the g7 energy
ministers
to discuss
further steps
while businesses
should do everything they can to source
oil from alternative sources they will
still be able it's important to
emphasize this they will still be able
to import
russian oil during this transition
period these measures target oil related
products
imports only the uk is not dependent on
russian natural gas
making up less than four percent of our
supply however madame deputy speaker i
will be exploring options to end this
all together
i want to make clear to the house that
we fully intend
and we must
end
our dependency on all russian
hydrocarbons in the meantime we need
more investment in north sea oil and gas
production as we make the move to
cheaper and cleaner power
turning off domestic production as some
are calling for at this moment
would be
completely
the wrong thing to do we're not going to
do it the prime minister has also
confirmed that the government will set
out an energy strategy to uh explain
the uk's long-term plans for greater
energy security including both renewable
and nuclear power building on our
10-point plan
this uh measure
uh and those being taken by our allies
uh in terms of the phase out the oil
phase out will move the west away from a
dependency on russian oil it will take
us on a road to building a stronger more
resilient british energy system
it will also increase the growing
pressure on russia's economy
and will ultimately hamper russia's
ability to impose
further misery uh on the ukrainian
people
[Applause]
edmund
thank you madam uh deputy speaker and
can i start by thanking the secretary of
state for his statement madam deputy
speaker we are united against russian
aggression
we stand together in solidarity with the
ukrainian people
and let me echo the admiration he
expressed for president zolensky
and his address to us yesterday his
bravery and eloquence was both
extraordinary and inspiring
on the secretary of state's immediate
decisions we know that putin's war
machine is being funded by oil and gas
that's why it's right for every country
to do what it can to isolate the regime
and every company to do so
so we fully support the government's
decision to ban
oil imports it is a right and welcome
step
and it is right also to work with the
companies and unions on how we implement
this policy
i'd like to ask secretary of state in
his reply maybe he could tell us what
assessment he has made of the impact of
the ban on petrol and diesel
prices
we also support him
in his decision to seek to find ways to
rid ourselves of russian gas imports and
i want to ask him about the wider energy
security context to his statement which
he talked about because i think it's
essential that we learn the right
lessons from this crisis although 50 of
our gas comes from the north sea and
only four percent from russia we pay the
same price for our own gas as that which
we import because we operate in an
integrated gas market
so madam deputy speaker we are
absolutely exposed to the rocketing
wholesale gas prices that we are seeing
currently up 100 on the month
and 800
on the year
the right lesson to learn is therefore
surely that we have to go much further
and much faster in developing homegrown
zero carbon power including renewables
and nuclear which can free us from the
whims of autocrats and dictators who can
use or use fossil fuels as a
geopolitical weapon does the secretary
of state agree this is the right lesson
and the policy will need to change
in particular does he agree we should
finally end the effective moratorium on
onshore wind in the planning regulations
which has denied us power each and every
year since 2015 equivalent to our gas
imports from russia
does he agree we should ramp up our
offshore wind so we go well beyond 40
gigawatts
and does he agree madam deputy speaker
it's time to finally get serious about
energy efficiency the best way of
cutting energy demand and where the
government has not succeeded in the past
years on the north sea madness speaker
there needs to be a phased transition
but will he now clarify the government's
position on fracking and will he confirm
that the moratorium
that was put in place will remain in
place no ifs no buts
no ifs no buts as fracking would not
make any difference to the prices
consumers pay
is dangerous and would take decades to
come on stream
they don't agree with me i've got a
position against fracking they support
fracking we'd love to know what the
secretary of state and the government
thinks and i'm sure they would too
finally let me ask him about the cost of
living crisis facing families
arising for what is happening to oil and
gas prices we have consistently warned
the government that their measures were
wholly inadequate for the rising energy
bills
i i asked the secretary of state today
will he undertake to tell the chancellor
that in his spring statement he must
come back with much much more help for
both families
and businesses
let me end by saying this madam speaker
we are united in our support for people
in ukraine we will support the
government in everything it does which
can cut off support for the evil and
barbaric butane regime and we urge the
government to learn the right lessons
from this crisis for our country so we
can achieve both energy security and
energy sovereignty
deputy speaker um
in his customary way he raised a large
number of questions
uh the majority of which i hope to deal
with
um in terms of his words against uh
putin's barbaric invasion
uh his
completely illegal actions i'm very
pleased
that he's reflecting our sentiments and
we have a mutual uh interest in making
sure that uh putin fails
as far as the cost of living uh is
concerned madam deputy speaker there was
an extensive uh intervention by my right
honourable friend the chancellor checker
and i think it's quite wrong for uh
opposition politicians to say that the
price cap which will be set in august is
going to uh necessarily be higher than
than what it is uh today we simply don't
know he will understand he will
understand he will understand that the
price cap will be set at a time uh
looking retrospectively looking at the
average price it may well be higher but
there are circumstances in which uh it
won't be increasing uh as much um as uh
he imagines and of course as is always
the case we have an ongoing uh approach
uh look at the at the price gap we speak
to off gem all the time
and there are off gem is engaging work
in terms of how the price uh cap is
calculated in terms of the north sea uh
i'm pleased to hear that he's very uh
keen to uh support investment in the
north sea in terms of
making sure that gas
is a key
uh
fuel that's something which i think many
people on uh the bench's opposite may
disagree with um and of course he's
absolutely right to stress uh an
increased focus on renewables and
nuclear power we are absolutely at one
uh in our agreement on this
fracking robert jan rick thank you very
much the business and energy minister
speaking there announcing that there's
going to be a meeting of g7 ministers in
response to this energy crisis tomorrow
he was giving further details there of
the announcement he made yesterday
online
about the uk government's strategy to
wean
the uk of russian oil and oil products
he said it's going to be phased out by
2022 saying it gives
businesses and industries plenty of time
to find alternative supplies and the
government will be helping them with
that so that's quasi quantum speaking
there in house of commons more on that a
little later on
now ukraine's president has been warning
of a humanitarian catastrophe if the
west doesn't do more to help his country
vladimir zelinski was speaking after a
polish plan to provide ukraine with
fighter jets was rejected by the united
states in the past hour ukraine issued a
warning about the chernobyl nuclear
plant because of a power cut however the
international watchdog says there is no
critical impact on safety
well let's take a look at the latest
developments on wednesday so far across
ukraine the capital kiev woke up again
to the sound of air raid sirens and
later the sound of explosions echoed
around the city
uh kharkiv chernahiv sumi and maropol
are all surrounded by russian forces and
continue to experience heavy shelling
arches joshi our correspondent
has an update on the story so far today
they're looking for survivors or the
injured
anyone who might still be alive under
the debris
this building like so many in sumi